hi and welcome to my video series of
mall bio explained in three minutes
where I explained the concept of mobile
in less than three minutes or so now
these videos are not so detailed but it
has all the necessary information to
save your ass before the day of your
exam and if you haven't yet subscribed
to my channel hit that subscribe button
and stay tuned till the end of this
video and in this installment we'll talk
about the cosmid which are a modified
plasmids and nut cloning vectors of
course they are better than the plasmids
and in this video we would understand
how they are better than the plasmids if
we break down the name Kozma is equal to
cos plus plasmid the cost came from the
cost sides in the lambda H vector and
the plasmid is just the normal plasmid
the cloning vector now let's understand
the fudge biology first to understand
the cosmics and how they are developed
we all know that bacteriophage can
infect bacteria with high efficiency and
if we look at the genome of these
bacteriophage they are DNA and there are
like several genes in these four genome
but the end of these four genome are
extremely sticky and these are called
cohesive sites or cos sites now these
call sites help the fudge to package
inside its head but these Co sites has
another function as well when the fudge
infect the bacteria and injects its
genetic material inside the bacteria
these cohesive ends ensures that this
circularize properly inside the bacteria
the circularization has its own
advantage this circularization which
happens due to the cost side brings the
@pn at B sides close to each other which
helped them to recombine in a site
directed recombination manner and help
them to get integrated into the fudge
genome into the bacterial genome
now if these core sites are 50 kilo base
pairs away then they could be
efficiently packaged inside the fudge
head but if the distance between two
core sites are less than 50 kilo base
pairs or less than 30 kilo base pairs
then no packing take place
now let's just look at a little bit
about the basic feature of the cosmic
vectors now these cosmic vectors are
modified plasmids and their carrying
capacity range from 37 to 52 kilo base
pairs and generally average size is 45
kilo base pair it has a multiple cloning
site like any other cloning vector where
there are a bunch of restriction enzymes
and where you can cut the vector to
insert your gene of interest it would
have a origin of replication such that
it could be propagated inside a bacteria
it has the cohesive side which would
allow it to get circularized
inside the bacterium and obviously it
has a resistance gene which would allow
selection right selection of the
recombinant inside a bacteria now let's
say we cut the cosmic vector with the
restriction enzyme and then we insert
our gene of interest which is somewhere
let's say 40 kilo base pair now they
would be ligated to the restricted
cosmic vector and this hole in this in
this whole vector schema if these cost
sites are somewhere 50 kilo base pair or
at least 30 kilo base pair away from
each other then they could be
efficiently packed in the fudge head so
all the recombinants would get packed
but if there are self ligated products
or any nonspecific product which are
smaller than the desired size then it
won't be packed inside the fudge head
and that's a good thing right
because we don't have nonspecific
products inside the fudge now when the
fudge infects and injects its DNA inside
the bacteria it would eventually
circularize because it has its cost
sites which are the cohesive ends which
would allow it to circularize and if we
talk about the utility of cause mates
there are mid-level carrying capacity
vectors they their carrying capacity is
not as less as the plasmid but not as
much as the back or yak so
they can be used in several purposes but
their biggest advantages in case of
plasmid in order to get the plasmid
inside the bacteria you have to do heat
shock method transformation or any other
method of transformation now well
transformation works but the efficiency
is not hundred percent but if you want
to deliver the gene inside the bacteria
and if you use cosmic type of vectors by
an infection by a fudge then this is
fairly efficient and fudge almost in
fact every single equal eye that it can
possibly infect so the process is very
efficient and plucks could be easily
formed from these cause means now once
inside the bacteria the consequence can
easily propagate it because it has its
origin of replication antibiotic
resistance gene so we can easily select
that as well
but there are certain disadvantages with
cos means cos means in a linear format
is not so stable and can acquire many
mutations and that's why even though it
was developed in 1970s it was later
discontinued
however initial days the lambda
replacement vectors were used to prepare
the cDNA libraries special especially
the lambda GT series but later on few of
these cause means are also used to
prepare cDNA libraries it's good to know
that they were useful at that time but
now there is literally no use of these
cosmic vectors even if they are they
were hypothetically superior than
plasmids but still it's not really used
these days I hope you enjoyed this video
and this video was informative if you
liked this video give a thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you